c'est un geste ou qu'elle les français
doivent s'habituer
depuis lundi la présentation du pass
sanitaire est obligatoire pour pouvoir
se rendre dans les cafés ou les
restaurants mais face à ces nouvelles
contraintes
la plupart des clients restent
compréhensifs ils ont été coopératif il
ya même qu'ils attendaient qu'on leur
demande ne pas de sanitaires en fait de
contrôler enfin aucun souci je lai et
donc je suis habitué à le présenter déjà
la médiathèque juste en face pourrait
céder à la bibliothèque
donc pour moi ya pas de y'a pas de
soucis c'est un problème sanitaire
donc je ne m'y contrat pour les
professionnels de la restauration la
mise en application du pass reste
difficile le contrôle s'ajoute à la
charge de travail d'un personnel souvent
sous-effectif pendant la période
estivale
au lendemain de l'entrée en vigueur de
nouvelles restrictions
le bilan reste mitigé c'était difficile
très difficile même il forme était plus
de personnel pour travailler au plus on
s'enfonce et des vacances en plus lundi
c'est tous les commerçants fanfare n'y
est pas et pas trop de monde qu'on aime
moins 2 mondial inquiet du manque à
gagner
les organisations syndicales réclament
le prolongement des dispositifs des
aides mises en place depuis le début de
la pandémie
pour aider les professionnels touchés
par les restrictions sanitaires